she's even faster
and I get us me forces for too much even
for me and now very everyone is dead
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my flash season 6 episode 7
video part one of the two-part
mid-season finale right before crisis on
Infinite Earths
so I'll explained the schedule at the
end of the video and remind everybody
about when everything is happening we're
doing the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
episode on the video so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet there were a whole bunch of Easter
eggs they are doing a lot of flash
rebirth stuff from the comics but top 10
WTF and Easter eggs starting with number
10 Ralph vs. Ramsay Rosa so he infects
Ralph with his black goo it interacts
with Ralph's DNA then he takes it back
out that's the key to him controlling
all those goo zombies from the previous
episodes he screams about his destiny to
save all of mankind typical villain
monologuing going all crazy and over the
top they explained that because Barry's
blood type is o-negative his speed
healing might be able to help Ralph
based on the arc of the episode I'm
assuming because they sent Ralph to an
Argos facility to finish healing that
they'll pay that off in next week's
episode and we'll find that his
sacrifice to save Ralph helped him live
and that'll just be one of the things
that helps him feel better about maybe
dying in sacrificing himself during
crisis on Infinite Earths oh I'm dying
so that they can live just like I saved
Ralph I almost died so that he could
live it'll make a lot more sense in a
couple weeks when crisis actually starts
but because of the transfusion
some of Ramsey's blood was able to
infect Barry and now he's got a mind
space ramsey the table to just pop up
anytime he wants and speak to him to try
and take over his body for the rest of
the episode and because he's inside his
mind he instantly has access to
everything that Barry knows so he knows
what Barry saw when he sent his mind
into the future to see crisis on
Infinite Earths
he's surprised to learn that there is no
version of events where he's still there
so that means that he either dies or
they throw him into one of chester p
trunks black holes and that's why he's
not around in any of the versions of
crisis Barry didn't say that Ramsay was
dead he just said that he wasn't around
for crisis number 9 welcome to black
holes so they're using the black hole
storyline for iris to investigate the
mystery of their organization they just
sort of tee that off with the guy
walking
Brown with the black hole pin on his
lapel why would you walk around wearing
that pin it'd be like a Bond villain
walking around wearing a specter pin to
let everybody know that he was a member
of the super secret organization Spectre
if you're not familiar with black hole
from the comics I'll talk about them in
a second they're a really big
organization from the flash rebirth
comics they get into a lot of speed
force research number eight the Speed
Force wormhole alien in the form of his
mother comes back to speak to Barry it's
probably the same form that he's spoken
to in the past even though it speaks of
itself in first-person like it's
collectively the same entity there's not
a bunch of different Speed Force
wormhole aliens it's all one
consciousness it's just always taken the
form of his mother because that's easier
for Barry to understand and connect with
but it gives in the business explains
what the stakes are for the episode he's
trying to take over your body you'll
become something so burst it even tells
him later in the episode all the best
parts of you will be subsumed even if
you're able to survive it won't be the
version of you that everyone's come to
know and love most of the episode for
Barry took place inside his head so
number seven the Spider Man far from
home Mysterio horror montage of
illusions they did the exact same thing
that Mysterio did during spider-man far
from home showing him a bunch of horror
like nightmares in how he might be able
to save everyone because we know that
Marvel exists within the world of the
flash maybe he also saw spider-man far
from home and thought that'd be a good
idea to borrow that trick from Mysterio
I loved the horror sequence of them at
Thanksgiving dinner in the reveal that
the black goo was inside the lasagna and
them all eating you had to remember all
the actors filming that scene having to
stuff their faces with that black goo no
idea what it's made of usually winds up
being a lot of corn syrup and food dye
to make it look like this black goo but
it is safe to eat like they're not
poisoning the actors while they're doing
this scene Berry didn't really start to
lose it till he saw the version of baby
Nora with the XS symbols spinning above
her head she was wearing a little
unicorn pajamas I just want to hold her
a little bit he really started freaking
out he shows him a different version of
the future newspaper flash saves
everyone then number six
Barry sees a reverse flash again for the
first time this season they kind of
acknowledge what happened in the season
5 finale with Nora getting wiped from
the timeline in Reverse flash but we
haven't actually seen him on screen yet
and he's a big part of crisis on
Infinite Earths
so it makes sense that they would wait
till
right before the crisis to sort of tease
him again I don't know when he's
actually physically going to be on
screen again I'm assuming if he doesn't
show up in next week's episode in a
post-credits scene he'll just show up
during one of the first episodes of
crisis because he is one of the most
powerful people on earth one I also
loved all the tombstones of the Dead
team flash members those are all the
people that have died since season one
he's trying to pin this all on Barry if
you've seen spider-man far from home you
know exactly how this plays out I did
think it was interesting that the Speed
Force when it would carry Barry from one
vision to the next like it speeds him
into his childhood bedroom to make him
feel safe
it almost looks like Nora's speed force
lightning with the two different colors
with the purple in the yellow color for
a brief second I thought that Nora might
have something to do with that or a
version of Nora from the future but the
way they played it during the episode it
was just the Speed Force wormhole alien
trying to rescue him number five the
black hole ultraviolet teaser the guy
that they questioned earlier in the
episode completely got blown up
no cameras anywhere saw anything but
there's an ultraviolet wavelength
signature on the little black hole pin
so very clearly black holes sent
ultraviolet to take care of this guy
before he could offer up any information
to Iris in her investigation if you're
not a big comic book reader I definitely
think they're going for the iris black
hole Ark from the flash rebirth comics
she's not featured quite as prominently
as she is on the TV show but is part of
the whole flash rebirth storyline she
starts to investigate black holes
separately from team flash because for a
long time in the flash rebirth arc she
did not know that Barry was the flash
they left that for way later
for the most part black hole is just an
evil organization that's in league with
Gorilla Grodd trying to manipulate and
use the Speed Force for its own gain it
turns into a much bigger thing with
Gorilla Grodd being the real big villain
I don't know how much of that they're
gonna do from the comics for now they're
just teasing black hole as an
organization so they could introduce any
of the characters from that black hole
arc in the comics Ryan and Mina are the
two speedsters that we have not seen on
the show yet that are connected to black
holes so I don't know if they're
intending on doing either of those
characters but they did a lot of Mina's
storyline with Nora last season number 4
Barry completely loses it on the Speed
Force wormhole alien and tries to kill
it in the form of his mother just like
reverse-flash killed his mother during
season 1 one of the
WTF moments of the episode it's just him
slowly going into negative flash mode
the vicious version of Barry Allen that
just gives in to all the negative
emotions that he's had pent up this
whole time all the stuff that he hasn't
dealt with yet the really interesting
thing in all this is that the Speed
Force wormhole alien says that they do
experience pain just not as Barry knows
it so hopefully they'll double back on
that in a future episode and just go
deeper on it like what is this pain that
you're talking about does it have
anything to do with the negative Speed
Force either way by this point in the
episode since it's a two-parter you
probably sense that he was definitely
going to become the negative flash by
the end of the episode so you kind of
knew how they were gonna play this I did
like their execution though the way they
made it seem like he beat him when he
came out of that coma also interesting
no killer Frost has a panic attack while
this is all going on she starts seeing
visions of Ralph and just completely
collapses part of the reason for doing
that is to sort of give her some sort of
problem of her own that she has to work
through some internal problem as they go
into crisis just to make things more
complicated for her but the plot based
reason is because they wanted Barry to
turn into the negative flash and that
wouldn't have happened had Caitlin been
able to step in and help Barry number 3
was iris writing the future newspaper
article if you go back and you read the
original newspaper articles sometimes
they're too tiny to read the text but
I'd be willing to bet that there are a
couple subtle minor changes but you
notice that the image of his face is way
clearer he's as the new version of the
costume with the chin strap just like
the one that they saw back in season 1
if you were to zoom in though you would
probably see some minor differences
because they have made a couple minor
changes to the story as things have
happened in the last six years but the
next big WTF moment is Nash wells
gaining access to the monitors secret
lair now these seven symbols are kind of
mysterious but I believe that they
correspond to the seven different
Paragons that he's going around
assembling like Barry Allen is a Paragon
Oliver is a Paragon Kingdom Come
Superman is a Paragon they're the a-list
heroes that the monitor is assembling
for his team to fight the anti-monitor
he also named drops Infinite Earths
which is a reference to comic book
crisis on Infinite Earths and I'm hoping
that once he breaches this door
something will happen to him that will
turn him into pariah wells but when
Barry wakes up out of the coma and
everything seems like it's totally fine
he wants to get right back to work most
of you probably sensed what the
twist was going to be that he didn't
beat ramsey and he's just pretending to
be okay so number one berry transforms
into the negative flash or reveals
himself as the negative flash he runs
back to ramsey and it also seems like
ramsey has turned into more of a comic
book version of bloodwork who's like
really huge because he absorbs so much
of the goo from different people when he
runs up you see the shadow is really
huge then shrinks back down into a human
form so I'm guessing they'll show us
what that actually looks like in part
two of the mid-season finale which will
be next week then the week after that
will be crisis on Infinite Earths
episode 1 first episode is going to be
Sunday night's second episode will be
Monday and then the third episode will
be the flash episode on Tuesday then
they go on break for a couple weeks come
back at the end of January for parts for
and parts 5 the legends episode in the
arrow episode if you're not a big comic
book reader though Barry was the
negative flash in the comics when he
fought blood work but the way he became
negative flash was very different the
reverse flash pushed him into the
negative Speed Force infecting him with
that energy and then he came back out as
negative flash this hulking monster that
looks kind of like what they're doing on
the TV show but obviously the TV show is
toned it way down they're using the
black dude to give him the negative
speed force effect but he still kind of
has Black Lightning like the black speed
force lightning when he was the negative
flash if he spotted any other big Easter
eggs in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments I will do a
trailer video for the next episode in
the next couple of days so look out for
that this is a new Mandalorian video
coming really soon so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see those videos but I post them
every one click here for the official
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer and
click here for the brand new Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 4 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]